The New York Times did an
audio interview with Donald Trump, and it's
truly bizarre. And it... it's starting to get
to the point where questions about
Trump's mental and emotional stability
really sort of can't be ignored. Uh, Trump said yesterday
in this interview that... that, ex-excerpts of which were
released by the New York Times,
that he never would have appointed Jeff
Sessions to Attorney General if he
had known that Jeff
Sessions was going to recuse himself
from anything Russia related. He
called that decision by Jeff Sessions, quote,
"very unfair to the President," which thi- this
entire thing of people being fair to Trump is yet another
way in which he's... he's sort of projected the fact
that everything he's done, really hasn't
been fair to anyone... the American people, other
elected officials,... But I'm sort of digressing from
from the main point about Jeff Sessions. He said
quote, "Sessions should have
never recused himself, and
if he was going to recuse himself, he should have told me
before he took the job, and I would have
picked somebody else," which makes
absolutely no sense on many levels; Number one,
before Jeff Sessions was selected by Donald Trump,
I mean, I guess, gi-, given, given
what appears to be Session's involvement, it's
possible, he could've... he could have, uh, foreseen
how this entire Trump/Russia thing was going to explode, but
why would Jeff Sessions have anticipated such a recusal, at the
very beginning of his selection process, and in addition to that,
Sessions really had no choice but to do that. The guy was
clearly involved in part of the
problem with Trump/Russia,
not recusing himself... and Trump
probably is too much of a political novice to even
realize this, Sessions *not* recusing himself
would probably have cost, uh, *caused* Trump
even more trouble. And Donald Trump
said, in this interview with the New York Times, that
it was Sessions' recusal that
ultimately led to the appointment of Special
Prosecutor, Robert Mueller, which is sort of an
odd perspective, because it... Tr- Trump seems to be
operating in a very simplistic world, where;
If "B" happened after "A"
it must have been caused by "A". While
it's true that the Special Prosecutor
was appointed after
the recusal of Jeff Sessions, there were endless
other factors and reasons that we ultimately ended up
with a Special Prosecutor, and the recusal of Jeff
Sessions was only part of the broader Russia sca...
Russia *question*, so to speak. In this same
*very* odd interview with the New York Times
Trump went after, not only Jeff Sessions, but
also went after fired FBI
Director, James Comey, saying that Comey tried to,
"leverage a dossier of compromising
material in order to keep his job."
Bear in mind that this is the same dossier
that for a long time Donald Trump
claimed didn't even exist. Later Trump
claimed that the contents of the dossier
were bogus, despite the dossier's
existence being real, but we've seen
uh, s- since that point, many
aspects of that blackmail dossier
confirmed, and of course, James Comey didn't put the dossier
together. It was put together by former
MI6 Operative, Christopher St-uh Christopher Steele.
But here's the crazy thing...
If Donald Trump is
criticizing James Comey, for
wanting to use a dossier of compromising
information against Donald
Trump, effectively wanting to "blackmail" Donald Trump...
Blackmail only works, if the
dirt you have is true. Trump is
effectively incriminating himself here, by saying, "I don't
like that Comey tried to use an incriminating report
about me, against me, to keep his job."
Whether or not that's true,
that would only even conceivably be
a viable strategy, if there's actual
incriminating information about Donald Trump,
and Trump just doesn't... Trump doesn't have the
wherewithal and intelligence to realize,
that by even making this allegation, he's
effectively incriminating himself. Uh...
Donald Trump also criticized, in
this interview with the New York Times, not only Jeff Sessions,
not only the fired FBI Director, James Comey, but also
the acting FBI Director, who tremporarily
replaced James Comey. He also criticized
the Deputy Attorney General, Rod
Rosenstein. He slammed Special
Prosecutor, Robert Mueller,
and sort of issued, like, a thinly veiled threat to Mueller.
He actually said, if
Robert Mueller starts looking at Trump's family's
finances, above and beyond
just Russia related stuff, that it
would cross a "Red Line," which is sort of
a threat from the President to the Special Prosecutor,  and
this is the guy that supposedly
is the most loyal, there's no one more loyal than Trump.
He's rebuking Jeff Sessions. He...
ya' know, the Flynn thing was a disaster. Trump
ended up having to force him to resign, uh... but
Trump also seems completely disconnected for reali...
from reality, because he again insisted, during this
New York Times interview, that he's not under investigation,
and that ship has long sailed. Trump is quoted
uh... in... in the um...interview as saying,
"I don't think we're under investigation.
I'm not under investigation. For what? I didn't do
anything wrong." That ship has sailed, Donny Boy.
Numerous reports now indicate...
and they kind of have for close to two months now,
that Robert Mueller *is* investigating Donald Trump,
both for his potential role in the collusion or
coordination with Russia, itself, as
well as his role in the cover-up,
including potential obstruction of justice.
It... It doesn't seem to me that Donald Trump is even
capable of, sort of, acting in a way
that doesn't seem suspicious or erratic,
and the question I came away with, from listening
to excerpts from this New York Times interview, is...
How is Trump even in that room? Who thought it was a
good idea for Donald Trump to be
interviewed by the New York Times? And a common
trait of total narcissists is that
they're super confident in their ability
to say anything they want, because they believe "Anyone
I talk to is going to be persuaded by my perspective,
and they're going to come away seeing it my way," and
that really appears to be affecting Donald Trump here.
We know Trump is a terrible legal client, right?
He doesn't listen to his lawyers. Lawyers worry that
Trump won't even pay them for their work. But this is
sort of a new low. Going after his
own current sitting Attorney General
and really everybody else. Total lack of
personal responsibility.
The video you just finished watching was made
possible by you, through the membership program.
You can sign up for membership at
DavidPakman.com/membership
We are viewer supported independent media.
You can use the coupon code: IVOTED17
for a 40% discount off of your membership.